the movie opens up with our protagonist
David Van Owen who drives to his newly
bought house his daughter Jessica is
also there to help him in relocating as
the duo wander around the house they
stumble upon a locked door in a closet
on the ground they find a $100 bill
which David picks up thinking that it
might be left by someone who lived there
earlier they don't pay much attention to
it and buy dinner with the money while
eating the father and daughter have a
brief conversation about the house it is
at this moment when Jessica dis closes
that she has been dating a guy named
Zack Kennedy and that she wants her
father to meet him through their
conversation we also learn that Jessica
is suffering from some health issues and
is struggling to pay her medical bills
she should have said that before they
spent all their money on the food David
tells her that he might be promoted at
his work and reassures her that he will
help her pay the bills with his salary
raise it appears that David Works in a
programming company which mainly focuses
on developing video games before
departing he invites her to come over on
the weekend so that they can have a
little slumber party Jessica isn't sure
if she can make it because she already
has plans with her boyfriend that
weekend however she promises to visit
him soon so long as he promises not to
call it a slumber party on her way home
Jessica calls her boyfriend and
expresses her concern for her father
here we learn that David has recently
gotten divorced and since then he is
always looking for company not wanting
to feel alone early the next morning
David is awakened by a car's horn upon
walking out he finds that it's a
landscape AP who wants to check what
needs to be done in his yard the man is
amused to hear David's wish to install
his own septic tank after taking a note
of the required stuff the landscaper
leaves informing David that he will be
back next week just then David receives
a call from his best friend Mark
prompting him to head towards his place
the two friends then talk over a beer
during which David shares his idea of
building his own septic tank he also
reveals that he has taken a huge
mortgage to buy the house because he is
confident that he will be promoted after
hanging out for a while a while David
returns back home and starts digging his
yard initiating the septic tank work a
few minutes later his shovel hits
something hard he quickly removes the
soil and unearths a huge wooden box
intrigued David lifts up the Box's lid
only to be startled by a human corpse
despite this he lifts up the lid the
second time and finds a huge sum of
money beside the corpse taking one
bundle he closes the box covers it with
soil as before and heads inside curious
about the authenticity of the he
examines them with a marker only to find
out they are genuine later that night
David is woken up by the sound of
footsteps he gets up and goes out to
check but finds no one the following
morning at work David's boss Mr Woo
shows him the project manager's office
which will be his if he manages to get a
promotion Mr Woo also offers him a few
days off since he's dealing with the new
hurdles in his life due to his divorce
however David assures him that he is
fine and he can continue with his work
that day David leaves early to visit a
bank to inquire about depositing a
substantial sum a bank employee informs
him of potential legal issues with such
a large cash deposit this scares David
so he lies that the money belongs to his
uncle and not him once back at home
David is unable to stop thinking about
the money as a result he digs the yard
again and brings all the cash inside he
begins counting it and then Stacks it up
adding up to more than $3 million
following this he hides the money in the
clock closet with a locked door later at
night David again hears some sound
emanating from downstairs he immediately
gets back grabs the baseball bat and
walks down to check he cautiously
Ventures outside the door only to be
startled by a cat believing that it was
the cat the entire time he walks inside
with a sigh of relief after checking the
money in the closet he starts turning
off the lights to go back to sleep
during this he suddenly sees the corpse
staring at him from outside which freaks
him out David then goes to check the
wooden box and discovers that the dead
man is indeed dead he wakes up the next
morning for work visibly exhausted with
dark circles under his eyes due to lack
of sleep his stress gets doubled when
his boss tasks him with completing the
project work two days ahead of the
deadline Mr Woo also promises him a
promotion to the most awaited position
of project manager if he manages to do
so later after work David returns home
and finds shoe prints on the floor which
aren't his size in a state of panic he
calls his daughter asking her to meet
him right away Jessica who is hanging
out with her boyfriend excuses herself
for an hour and drives to see her dad
they meet at a coffee shop where David
shares about the substantial amount of
money however he avoids disclosing the
source of it and pretends to be working
on something else he confides in Jessica
about his fear of failing at work but
she reassures him that he'll be fine
back home David rechecks the money as if
it has become a part of his daily
routine he then begins cleaning the
mysterious shoeprints and then prepares
his suit for his work the next day after
finishing the chores he turns off the
light only to be startled by the sight
of his own suit in the dark I've really
been letting myself go he takes a moment
to calm himself down but he soon Hears A
noise from outside he looks out through
his window and sees a figure resembling
the dead man walking towards the house
David hurriedly grabs a kitchen knife
and runs out to confront the figure but
as usual he finds no one there believing
that this is happening because of the
the stolen money he puts all the dollar
bundles into a trash bag throws it into
the wooden box and seals it with
multiple Nails the next day at the
office David can't focus on his work as
his mind is preoccupied by the thoughts
of the money he suddenly recalls a
mysterious door within the closet
prompting him to sneak out of the office
to check on it he uses a drilling
machine to open the door but his efforts
prove futile amidst this David receives
a call from the landscaper reminding him
that he will be coming to his place on
Friday to run renovate the yard after
the call David Goes to the yard removes
the nails around the wooden box and
opens it again this time he proceeds to
check the pockets of the dead man and
retrieves a wallet along with some keys
at night as David walks up to his fridge
to look for something to eat the dead
man suddenly charges at him but the next
second he snaps out of sleep revealing
that it was just his nightmare as days
pass by he starts experiencing such
horrific nightmares more often which
causes him to be deeply unsettled one
day David takes a day off from work
retrieves a bundle of dollar notes from
the wooden box and purchases several
security cameras afterwards he installs
these cameras both inside and outside
his house also adding some lights to his
yard the surveillance system is
accessible from his bedroom and
everything can be lightened up with a
single click of a remote he has taken
this measure to identify and confront
whatever has been causing disturbances
during the night time in the next scene
David uses the acquired key to unlock
the door within the closet upon doing so
he uncovers a secret passage leading to
The house's basement with the help of
his phone's flashlight David heads down
and discovers a grim sight a number of
lifeless bodies wrapped in plastic bags
overwhelmed with panic he hastily
Retreats and heads to his kitchen he
then considers alerting the police but
he soon hesitates because of the
millions of dollars at stake that very
night David is awakened by his security
alarm swiftly turning on all the lights
he checks the CCTV footage on his
monitors at the same time a thunderstorm
causes a power outage plunging the
surroundings Into Darkness this induces
a moment of panic but power is restored
shortly as soon as the monitor restarts
it reveals the dead man standing outside
his bedroom the figure also stares at
the camera as if it's aware of David
watching him shortly after the dead man
descends the stairs prompting David to
grab a baseball bat and pursue the
corpse outside in the process he
accidentally steps on the broken pieces
of glass which results in his foot
bleeding despite the pain he channels
his inner John mlan and reaches the yard
shouting at the figure not to mess with
him he also opens the wooden box and
yells at the dead body to open his eyes
but the corpse remains motionless the
following morning David awakens and
finds himself sleeping beside the dead
body he hastily gets up and vomits
realizing he is running late for work he
rushes inside cleans up and gets dressed
as he is about to drive away he sees the
dead man standing in the yard staring at
him this time David doesn't freak out
and instead steps out of his car to
confront the figure seeing this the
corpse walks back to the box and lies
down frustrated David approaches the
dead man and yells at him but the corpse
is again not moving having had enough
David Gets a chainsaw and rips the dead
body splattering blood everywhere after
this he goes to work with blood all over
himself there Mr Woo chastises him for
showing up at work in such a condition
however David who is by now completely
mentally unstable yells back at his boss
and even uses some cursing words as a
result of this Mr Woo fires him from the
company and instructs the security
guards to throw him out David drives
back home and finds the landscaper who
has discovered the dead body in the yard
the man tries to call the police but
David in a violent Outburst strikes his
head with a hammer and bludgeons him to
death following this he wraps the
landscaper body in a plastic bag and
drags it down to the basement aligning
it with other dead bodies he also does
the same thing to the corpse in the
wooden box later that night David is
once again alerted by a security alarm
upon reviewing the camera footage she
spots the dead man again in his kitchen
armed with a bat he cautiously descends
the stairs and attacks his best friend
who is actually there to check on him
however David hallucinated Ates Mark as
the dead man and ends up killing him
with the drilling machine after this he
takes the dead body to the basement in
the morning he again brings the money
back into the house by this point in
time David has already gone insane as he
shows irrational behaviors such as
talking to himself in the mirror playing
games with the money bag and even
watching movies with it he even bought
himself a subscription to Hulu one day
David wakes up to the sound of the
doorbell upon answering it he sees that
his daughter's boyfriend before Zach can
introduce himself David Stomps his Bat
on his head knocking him to the ground
after this he wraps the still conscious
sack in the plastic bag before dragging
him to the basement not long after
Jessica shows up and quickly senses
something is a Miss but before she can
comprehend the situation David leads her
to the basement where he knocks her
unconscious a few moments later Jessica
regains her Consciousness only to find
herself chained to a pipe David
approaches her and tells her that he
knows when why she is here to seize his
money the girl breaks down in tears and
claims that she's just here to see him
hearing this David asserts that he knows
how to fix this and walks away leaving
his daughter and her boyfriend to a grim
fade in the final scene we see the
insane David getting dressed in a suit
and heading out to the yard amidst the
rain he pours all the money into the
wooden box and buries himself along with
it he probably took this step to stop
his Madness and greed from going any
further further or perhaps for the curse
to
continue subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching